[Music]
thank you
but before we get going I'd like to give
you a quick reminder to subscribe to our
YouTube channel you will not regret
subscribing to our YouTube channel to do
that you click the Subscribe button at
the bottom of your screen and also tap
the Bell icon to make sure you get
reminders and never ever miss an episode
now let's talk about e-bikes or
electronic bicycles which seem to be a
divisive topic Peter Hitchens has
written a Dippity forthright piece in
the magazine this week about how much he
dislikes them uh and I'm joined by him
now hello Peter good morning I'm also
joined by Henry down the line Henry from
the financial times Henry Mance uh who
is a fan a supporter of e-bikes
um Peter I'll start with you because you
wrote the piece you're an Enthusiast for
cycling
uh as you say in the piece but you
really don't like ebike yes they're a
fraud uh they look they look like bikes
they make people think that they're
riding bikes and they they also are
allowed into the cycle Lanes which it
took Decades of campaigning uh to get in
which is supposed to be free of Motor
Vehicles and they are Motor Vehicles
they're bike-shaped objects but they're
actually motorbikes and many of them can
go extremely fast and many of them are
very heavy indeed and so the whole
battle which took which I took part in
which took past 40 years to get special
spaces on the roads for for
human-powered lightweight silent clean
bicycles has now been tossed to one side
so these horrible themes can go whizzing
and whining along along bike tracks and
excessive speeds and we aren't safe
anymore and you think people should have
a license to to write they are motor
vehicles and all Motor Vehicles in this
country until very recently until the
201 chaps was it was the social the
transport had to had to be ridden by
people who were licensed and now this
has been dropped both for e-bikes and
for their hideous cousins the e-scooter
with results which I think will carry on
bothering us for many years to come and
people will wonder in times to come why
were so stupid as to make these things
legal and to allow people to ride them
without any serious qualification I have
a motorcycle license
and it's quite a hard thing to get and
they're actually quite hard things to
write and I think if you're going to
ride motorbike you should you should
learn how to do it and go to get a
license have you have you been on an
eBay have you tried it no they give you
red myth as soon as I see that I can't
see any points in them uh if I once if I
wanted to use Motor Vehicles I would but
I deliberately gave up those Vehicles as
far as I could many years ago and why
should I start doing so because
someone's produced a motor vehicle that
looks like a bicycle and isn't
Henry you are mentioned in this piece uh
I think you were described as being
typical of Metropolitan trendys who ride
e-bikes uh how do you respond to this
charge
I mean I take it as a huge compliment
Freddie and um rarely but I think
Peter's problem is that he's too young
and uh and fit and uh and full of energy
and he doesn't quite appreciate the you
know the role that e-bikes can play it's
actually quite nice to discuss this
topic because you say it's very divisive
but it's nice to discuss it with someone
with like Peter who gets the principal
and who is on board with changing
changing what our cities look like
rather than someone who who just wants
to continue throwing more cars down the
same streets which uh I think has had
lots of uh bad effects and and uh really
whether you're on the left or the right
there should be a a good case for uh
cycling and active active travel being a
bigger part than the more SUVs Etc but I
think
um I'm Peter's wrong to say that these
are basically motorbikes the real
difference with me bikers you still have
to Pedal to get any support from the
motor so you can't just sit on it and
whiz up a hill
um but uh and and these bikes although
they're a bit sturdier than the pedal
bike you might be used to they're not a
motorbike right a line bike which people
will see around London weighs about 35
kilograms a motorbike would be 10 times
that and you know you know a Volkswagen
Golf is is over a ton so really these
things do still belong in the segregated
cycle Lane and what I think they really
do is open up cycling to a whole range
of people who don't have Peter's energy
who live on a hill you know London is
not Amsterdam
um you know we can't we can't change the
geography we need to get more people's
cycling and offering them a bit of
assistance making a bit less hard work
is one way of doing that
except that it isn't I I you you may
have to actually turn the pedals and to
get an eBay to go uphill but you're not
doing what I'm doing when I go uphill uh
I often have to stand on the pedals to
go uphill uh but it I know that it's
extremely valuable exercise it's sweet
for you to call me young I am in fact
nearly 72 uh but the the truth is that
if I am fit that it's because I have
been you doing the hard business of
peddling a powerless bicycle for many
years often uphill and if people want
Fitness from bicycles they have to do
that and there's no point to taking any
any ee bicycle I'm overtaken by by them
all the time by people who obviously
haven't been as I've been cycling for
decades uh who just get on them and can
achieve speeds without any real serious
effort it takes me a really major effort
to get to they are not in even remotely
comparable in their ability to provide
exercise to to proper bicycles and they
may not be as heavy as motorbikes I
agree with you about that but that the
the ordinary ones the ones constantly
picking up from where they're dumped on
the pavement we're two and a half times
as much as an ordinary bicycle and the
the great big cargo machines can be
about five times as much and these are
really are very powerful motor vehicles
but they are motorbikes because they're
bicycles which have a motor they're
possibly more comparable to
the things which were actually called
mopeds probably 40 or 50 years ago the
word is now widely misused and there
were there were motor assisted bicycles
but you had to have a license for those
and again you could you you had to Pedal
them but the pedals did a little bit but
the most it didn't most of it let's not
pretend the motor is doing most of the
work without the most of the things
would be simply too heavy to ride what I
sense is I think when anesthesia came
along in the 19th century there were
some doctors who who opposed it on the
basis that you know people should suffer
and it was a good idea to to get a sense
of their pain that was helpful for the
medical process uh I think some of that
may still be around in in the way we
approach childbirth but um and that's
kind of the what the attitude that I see
seeping through from Psalms uh you know
traditional cyclists towards ebike the
idea that cycling should be a very
active thing it should you know it
should be hard on a rainy day it should
be hard to go up a hill this will get
you fit and the problem is that a lot of
people just haven't warmed to that I
mean I'm very happy to go on a normal
bike as well as an e-bike I enjoy it but
a lot a lot of people just haven't
wanted to do that they've got in their
cars instead and so how do we get them
out of their cars we offer them a
slightly easier cycling experience
there's many ways of getting people out
of course the principle one which of
course the Swiss is very good that's
just providing first-rate public
transport that gets people out of their
cars you're never going to get an awful
lot of people immediately to start
cycling well a lot of people don't
realize is I think the the Dutch until
about the late 50s and early 60s were
just as calm out as we were in their
cities were just as Clark and just they
took an actual decision as a government
and a people to turn away from this and
to promote cycling and it's taken many
many years to get to where they are now
and of course they have the curse of the
e-bike too which is strongly opposed by
many Dutch cyclists because they don't
want these things in cycle days but the
truth is that it would it will take a
long time I'm not it starts to do with
anesthetic and that's one of the reasons
I ride a motorbike anymore is that I I
had a very bad accident on one and I I
was lying by the roadside considerable
pain I was very glad when I got
aesthetic it's not remotely comparable
uh to the to the minor discomfort you
feel when you paddle a basketball uphill
as silly a non-comparison so let's let's
not have it people it's true that
cycling is a bit difficult and and quite
a lot of people find things that are a
bit difficult uh too hard to do well
okay let them uh if they if they want to
ride Motor Vehicles ride on the road I
don't mind if they want to write these
things about on the road it's if they
come whizzing Along on cycle tracks and
you're supposed to go at 15 miles an
hour and they're supposed to be governed
by little widgets which don't let them
go any faster it's horribly widely known
that these things couldn't be tweaked
and you can you can go far faster than
that and everybody knows that they do
and so here you have on cycle lens
objects which look like bicycles tearing
by perhaps 30 even 35 40 miles an hour
very heavy if they hit you you'll be
very badly hurt and the whole purpose of
the cycle and to segregate the
vulnerable it's like this the human
human frame on a small lightweight
machine from heavy traffic has been
undermined in a matter of I think two
years it's gone from from Bliss being on
cycle Lanes in London to being an
absolute nightmare is Henry it's a
problem not just what's going on the
lanes but the Clutter uh Outside The
Spectators office at the moment there
are three human forests which is one of
the rental uh systems if you like of
e-bikes in London uh and that's what
people object to the most I suppose
submission plays to both of you is that
they do clutter up Pavements uh there
are e-bikes everywhere and there are
also e-scooters everywhere
um is that the is that a problem do you
think
yeah yeah and I think that we should
hunt very hard for the three spectator
journalists who have left those bikes
outside uh outside the office
um but no I I think I think you're right
and I think when these new technologies
come along they do bring teething
troubles I mean do you remember when
mobile phones came along and everybody
was talking very loudly in train
carriages and it seemed like our future
would be a complete hell of listening to
other people's mobile phone
conversations and we sort of developed
Norms around that and anyone everyone
texts now anyway so no one no one ever
picks up the phone
um and I I do think that some of the
complaints around e-bikes are are things
that we could manage a bit better in in
Paris and Peter knows the case very well
but in Paris they've just had a
referendum
um on Banning not e-scooters but
e-scooter rentals on the basis that you
know people who own their own e-scooter
they tend to to you know be fairly
responsible with it and they you know
stick to the rules and they don't have
two or three people going on the same
scooter and they don't leave it lying
around on the pavement but people who
rent one from company like lime they
they may be a bit more Carefree about it
and a bit sort of uh not such good
citizens and I think the Clutter is a
real problem if you're in a if you're in
a wheelchair or if you're trying to uh
just walk down a pavement
um then then they're a nuisance so you
know finding a way in which there's
designated parking areas and people have
to pay very high fees if they don't
leave it in those parking areas that
seems to me the way forward but it
doesn't seem to be an insoluble problem
that you should throw out e-bikes
altogether well why were they licensed
in the first place they would they were
completely illegal until about recently
and suddenly there's an explosion of
them uh there's no aggression of
throwing them out the the real argument
is why why we took this step which is
still in my view reversible and whether
it was wise to do it's not just I have
to say on cycle layers that these things
would be found I was quite a broken
house your wonderful officers a few
months ago and I was nearly sent to my
reward by any bike which must have been
doing 30 miles an hour along the
pavement in the city of London and and
the the unfortunately am I I still have
enough obsessive hearing to notice it
coming but it was very close around the
thing and that's the second time in my
life that I've come close to being
erased by by anybody they are dangerous
and they as I say they are not properly
licensed they're not properly regulated
anything of this level of danger in any
other area of life would be regulated
and so it's licensing these things are
just allowed out everywhere and they are
growing in number every day there are
more of them and if if nobody does
anything about it soon we are going to
regress it and and here I am just just
making this point and also trying to get
a cycling campaigners who have accepted
them in a rather open mouth way to see
there's a huge difference between a
human pads silent machine and a heavy a
heavyweight motorbike capable of 30 or
40 miles an hour and they shouldn't
allow them to be mixed up and they
shouldn't be allowed on cycle lens and
they also shouldn't be allowed and
painless one other thing which we need
to do of course is to is to introduce a
fantastic idea in this country which I I
think other countries have it's just
called a police force you hire people to
enforce the law and you make them walk
around the streets stopping people who
break the law we don't have one of these
uh at least if we have I haven't seen
any trace of it but if you have one of
those then we could also sort this thing
out on that emphatic note
as you agree with you on on that that
you know where is the enforcement where
is the enforcement of bad driving
everywhere but let me give you an
example I mean I have a normal bike
which I will take occasionally into the
office but I'll take around town and
then if I want to go somewhere with my
kids then I put them on the back of a
cargo bike they get strapped in and it's
only possible let's not get started on
cargo bikes let's not do that that's a
whole nother too we'll do that in the
next uh the next Edition but Henry and
Peter thank you very much uh for coming
on spectator TV
um it's an enjoyable debate
[Music]
thank you
foreign